ils vont arriver avant 8 heures
t'inquiète pas on va empêcher
l'expulsion
la police ce matin tu te souviens bien
ils sont en train d'embarquer sa fille
je suis l'avocat de Badia et lataoui je
dois la retrouver aujourd'hui
[Musique]
plan expulsion est imminente
on va pas les laisser faire
[Musique]
désolé mais on manque de ressources
étudier le cas concret enfin je
vous parle d'un cas exceptionnel on gère
les pires merdes possibles on fait ce
qu'on peut
c'est ma maison j'ai pas encore perdu on
doit stopper leur procédure
mettez-vous à ma place
[Musique]
tu promets de l'aide à tout le monde
mettez-la pour personne j'ai tout raté
ma vie tu n'as rien raté du tout
j'ai besoin de savoir c'est très
important
[Musique]